so were there any openings that you that
you wanted to
like ask about uh from from either color
well i mean right now i really need to
think about what my strategy is going to
be as black for opening i mean sure
for white it's like you know i have some
thoughts on
i have some training on vienna i have
some on ponziani
etc but as black
you know i one one idea i'm thinking of
is black except again it gets to what
you said where
you know all of a sudden i've got
nareditsky watching my stream
um is that i've been thinking of um
king's indian because it's feels
relatively straightforward with just a
couple of exceptions from white
and so from a memorization standpoint it
seems maybe favorable but again you know
next thing i know who knows who is uh
feeding the moves to whoever and then i
just i have someone very prepared
right right and um i mean this is where
i can try and come in
and give you some some recommendations
um when you say king's indian um
this usually refers to an opening you
play against d4
yes where you you employ the setup
knight f6
g6 bishop g7 castling i've seen your
online games and you
there's a lot of games where you just do
this against anything right well that's
a that's question one which is
if i see e4 do i just abandon this idea
altogether
so when you play against e4 you can't
quite
play a typical king's indian okay
um and i'll show you why um
like we can use this game as an example
just in the opening this is a game i
think you played earlier today
on chess.com and you
you played kind of the the typical
king's indian setup
the problem with doing this is you can
get hit with e5
right and and frequently i do yeah not
everyone will punish you but some people
will punish you
yeah um anyone who nier ditski coaches
will
will punish you and you just don't want
to subject yourself to
um such kind of cruelty um
so if you wanted to still play something
that's
like that kind of resembles the king's
indian you can play what's called
the modern or the pierce which usually
involves d6
important move to include to uh to
discourage e5
and then whatever white does then you
continue development
and you can kind of live happily without
worrying about e5
in the event of e5 you just take it so
the
the most relevant modification would be
that i'm i'm inserting d6 exactly
before i moved the night out okay right
now
i i would still um i was actually
thinking about this
uh before our call in terms of like what
openings i can recommend that
that would offer you some more comfort
and that would still be simple to learn
because even when you play like um a
modder in your appearance and you play
d6
you're basically giving white the entire
center yes
and it's kind of i mean it's playable
there's still
like high level players that will do
this but it's not the most pleasant
thing
to just give white the entire uh entire
kind of pawn center
and for you to play with less space now
what about d6
e5 so d6 e5
it's um it's also playable there's a
name for this it's uh it's a fill door
sometimes players will play e5 first and
then d6 right
it still has kind of a passive
reputation because you're you're
blocking in this bishop
right um probably what i would
recommend against e4 it's it still
resembles
kind of appears or modern but it's a
little bit more aggressive
and it's to start actually with a
sicilian
you start with c5 because you're
discouraging white from playing d4
and then your general plan um will be
what's called the dragon uh the dragon
variation
which i don't know if you've heard of
before but it's one of the most common
defenses in chess
now let me ask in this we we may get a
conflict here
levy rosman says do not play the
sicilian as
black until you were raided 2000 and i'm
like still a few months short of that
yeah um that's actually funny um
i i have a vague memory of him saying
that
but yeah this is probably just a
coaching
like a difference in coaching philosophy
yeah and this will also kind of go back
to the
the point that we shouldn't spend so
much time in openings
right but we should at least give you a
starting point
of something simple to play yeah my goal
is
not to get tripped up early right and
not even have a reasonable shot at the
middle game because of some big mistake
in the first five or six moves
definitely um so the reason why i would
recommend the dragon and i i would
imagine like if i talked to levy
this would be some compromise because
out of there when you say sicilian
this could include over a dozen
different variations
um like sicilian it's a very it's a vast
kind of
very flexible opening um but i would
make the argument that the dragon
variation
is the simplest to learn for beginners
okay because it employs
it basically includes c5 and employs the
same setup
that you see in a king's indian or
appearance ah okay
but it's so it's a little bit more
comfortable because you're like whenever
white plays d4 you just take it
okay um it still takes some
some experience and uh some knowledge
but i think based on like your
competition especially in pot champs
it's an opening that you can get by with
it's very solid
and you're gonna have like a very safe
king and and more kind of aggressive
potential in the middle game
okay and that's interesting to me yeah
i i can show you like how a typical sort
of sicilian variation would go
or a dragon variation um many times
white will try and get in the move d4
uh usually starting with knight f3 okay
we should know if white plays d4
immediately
and i'm just going to give you a hard
rule whenever white plays d4
you should take the pawn got it so um
if i plays d4 immediately you take the
pawn if the queen ever lands on d4
you immediately attack with knight c6
okay
um and then you you gain time chase away
the queen develop a knight
and then once the queen goes away i
start my sort of king's indian set up on
the left
yes so if the queen moves over then you
can
you can go you're familiar with the term
fiance right
oh yeah very much so intimately familiar
very good yeah because this is uh
i guess this is what you did even even
when it wasn't so good in that
previous game you looked at but uh
yeah you just go for the fiance setup
and in this case
the knight prevents white from from
going to e5
but usually you include this move as
well more often white will play knight
f3
okay um now here
i recommend starting with d6
and the idea is you want to play knight
f6
but you don't want to run into this move
right and that's the purpose of d6
exactly and now now you're ready to
uh to employ your setup let's imagine
white plays d4
yep i take right exactly boom takes
and now and i have six yep and you go
for g6
bishop g7 and castling got it um
and very often when you play the dragon
you're
you're looking to develop the king side
before you you really touch anything on
the queen side
now with knight f6 you attack the pawn
usually white defends
you go for g6 and
almost always your next two moves will
be bishop g7 and castling
um and it's from this position where
white has like a variety of different
setups
but most often you can stick with
with bishop g7 castling later knight c6
and it's you get a position where your
pieces are on
on nice squares you have some nice
pressure against the center
you have two center pawns white only has
one center pawn
um you have this half open c file which
more long term
sometimes you'll you'll develop your
bishop and then get a rook to to the c
file um and i'd say the best way to
to learn this is just by playing it
um now it theoretically at least in this
position
where is the ideal place for the light
squared bishop
yeah for lightsword bishop um there's a
few different
setups white will will go for usually
the bishop oh i'm sorry
i meant for my light squared vision oh
for your oh yeah um
so this bishop is actually the last
piece you look to develop
in this in this variation because right
off the bat it doesn't have a great
square
right um like if it ever goes to g4 y
can easily play f3
so very often it will kind of hold back
and
and just go to d7 okay that's typically
where i end up with it
in these positions or sometimes i'll go
for b7 if i think that there's some
advantage to it
that's also an idea yeah and there's
cases like later on in the middle game
let's say white plays like a very kind
of simple set of bishop e2 bishop g7
castle and castling um there is times
where you'll go for a6 and b5
and the bishop can can land it on on the
queen side fiance
yeah and then then you have two bishops
kind of piercing through the center
influencing all four center squares got
it
um but i i don't know if i want to dig
like too
deep into like specific opening theory
but if you understand
kind of the main setup the reason why
you play d6 the reason why you start
with c5
i think this will offer you perhaps a
bit more comfort
than what you've been doing as black
yeah so to run it back this approach
would generally be
um i'm playing c5 followed by d6
taking on d4 at any point where that one
comes forward
if the queen then recaptures i
immediately play knight to c6
and then as possible depending on what
white does
i develop the king's indian setup on the
left
uh eventually develop the the
b8 knight to c6 and then figure out what
the
what makes sense for my light squared
bishop exactly
yeah and i i think that will offer yeah
as i said that will offer us just some
more uh more pleasant positions
um rather than than having just a space
deficit from her from early on
and then in terms of a6 and b5 i would
go to that
if what happens yeah so
then it really depends and that's like
when i
mentioned a6 b5 that's like one
middle game idea to add to your toolbox
okay
that would not be i wouldn't replace
some of these earlier moves with that
it would just be for later on for later
on yeah like if you're not sure what to
do
rather than playing just some random
random move that you just don't have a
purpose for
it's always good to look for look for
ideas that improve your position
got it and actually in this position
rather than starting with a6 usually
it's more typical to play knight c6 yeah
like the most natural square for the
knights
and then um
and then the game can can branch out in
many ways but like
at least you're you're completing the
opening you're following principles and
you're not falling victim to
to any tactics got it
so i know like usually uh when studying
openings is black
there's it's it's a bit more difficult
for a lot of players
because white is usually the one trying
to attack you
um early on and then sometimes you're
more on the defensive
sure um now we should also address
uh if white plays d4 okay
because this is another move that you'll
run into a lot and this is where i'd
recommend that you stick with a king's
indian
okay um you can't really like c5 isn't
as strong here
because it allows white to just grab the
center even more
um so
i guess i'd like to ask you just as kind
of a quick test how would you play
king's indian
from this position um well i think
first i would go knight to f6
good then pawn then bishop exactly yeah
you play knight f6 to prevent light from
playing e4
right let's say c4
um g6 yeah and you should have
i just made you a contributor so you
should have ability to move the pieces
as well
okay i'll play this
so i played my bishop right uh oh maybe
we got unsynced
um
you see bishop g7 though right bishop g
yes i see i played it yeah so this is a
case where i could i could grab the
center and now i'm curious what would
you do here um
i think i would castle and then if i
need to i would maybe undevelop the
knight to e8
is that is that a terrible idea that's
actually so this idea is actually
it's been played at like very high
levels um
i wouldn't recommend it because it's a
it's a bit ugly but passive
yeah the simpler approach is just to
play d6
so sticking with the same idea delay
talk about earlier okay
exactly um let's say knight of three
i think now i cast now castling let's
say
i'll just keep developing
oh i'm not seeing your move for whatever
i don't know why we keep getting
unsynced let's see
the buttons below the board should be
green yeah they're turning red and then
i'm clicking them and then they go green
again
oh that's strange um okay now i see
bishop to e2
yeah and now the question is like what
would you play as black in this position
so i i mean i think i would
think about c5
or knight to d7 oh no actually i don't
want to do well if i do that i'm sort of
committing to
eventually putting the bishop on b7
which maybe i don't want to do
i think i would look at either e5 no not
e5 i would probably look at c5
okay so you mentioned you mentioned a
bunch of moves here i just want to
identify
like all the moves you mentioned c5 you
mentioned 97 you mentioned e5
um it's funny like the the move i would
recommend you you rejected right away
which is e5
ah interesting um and
this is maybe something that's different
when you compare the king's indian to
like the sicilian dragon
in sicilian dragon you almost never play
this move
but here you play e5 with intention of
trying to poke it like center and um
at first okay there's kind of a a long
tactical sequence
where at first it looks like white has
two attackers right
black only has one defender sure so it
looks like white can win a pawn
however your pawn on e5 is
we we can call tactically defended by
the bishop
and we can see how this plays out let's
imagine white takes
yep you take back right um
now the queens are staring each other to
make things simple let's say white takes
your queen
you take back and white takes on
e5 yes so you just lost a pawn
uh however there is a move here
to uh to basically try and win the pawn
back
so i want to get the knight out of the
way
so that my bishop attacked
attacks uh the knight on the on e5
um if i take the pawn on e4 then we
trade knights there
i'm sorry we don't trade knights i lose
my knight but then i take a knight back
and that essentially wins back the pawn
exactly yeah so
this is basically what enables you to to
play e5 safely
is that you have this tactic and uh the
resulting position is actually pleasant
for black
because you you have a nice open
position you have the rook on the open
file
your bishops can enter and uh
there's not too much to worry about okay
um so if you know through e5 that would
be
that that would be already like a very
good start this is just a very typical
king's indian idea
um i can go maybe three like three moves
further i can give you just a better
sense of what to do in the middle game
okay um very often white will castle
here
and then rather than taking right away
you can apply more pressure
to this pawn on d4 with just a simple
developing move
now i bring the knight out to c6 exactly
okay
and you're trying to entice white to
take
if whatever it takes you're happy to
kind of get this
kind of simple position everything's
defended for you
um and if white plays d5
um this is actually a move that most
king's indian players look forward to
even though playing king's indiana is
black exactly
okay yeah um because even though white
gets more space
the structure is a bit more defined and
okay you're gonna move your knight to e7
and your plan going forward in the
middle game
is to remove this mic from f6 sometimes
back to e8 back to d7
and then go for f5 and then even later
f4
and this sort of structure it should
look very very similar
to the system you play as white
where you basically have this nice pawn
chain directed
towards your opponent's king now this is
like the absolute main line like if you
played
good players you'd be likely to get this
position
um but uh i think this would be nice
like if you ever get the structure
then just knowing about this this f5
idea we can imagine
if white plays a move like b4 um
you can even play knight h5 here and
you're going you're going for the
kingside attack
where um once you get the pawn to f4 of
you you have a lot of attacking ideas
involving the pawn storm and if white
takes my pawn on f5
i take back with my g d pawn and then
later i push to f4
yeah so we can imagine like rookie one
let's say f5
uh white takes um you actually have a
pleasant choice here
but uh you could take really with with
either
minor piece or with your pawn
um and then this is where kind of
tactics can
can come into play yeah so like one idea
i would have here would be
because i have the rook on f8 i might
like to at some point have some kind of
discovered attack with the rook
i can't easily get the pawn out of the
way but i could get the bishop or knight
so that might
push me to take with one of the minor
pieces instead of the pawn
yeah i think that's very good reasoning
um so a move like bishop
five where you you basically develop
your your only undeveloped piece
um then then yeah you keep the file open
and that file could very often be used
as
an attacking weapon yeah and this um
i mean this idea is reminiscent of what
you play as white
uh i i'm pretty sure levy showed you
like some similar concepts with
the rook having the half open file now
is it relevant here
as a reason also not to take that pawn
with my g-pawn
that the g-pawn defends the knight on h5
yeah so this is where it could get
tactical um
because your knight's undefended and
this is something like you always want
to sense a danger
yeah i'm pretty sure here it's okay even
though white has this battery
directed towards your knight um
if white word should try and exploit
this let's say by moving the knight from
f3 and taking the pawn
the nice thing for you you can take back
and then this knight is hanging
ah knight's also pinned to the rook and
if white goes for this
then you're actually attacking both
rooks oh yeah yeah so that's in my favor
so that could very quickly just uh go
very bad for white
now i probably have to be realistic that
i'm not going to be seeing that far
ahead in these games
at my level as we like to say
um yeah so like most of what you should
be concerned about is just like
searching for or scanning the position
for undefended pieces
looking for the forcing moves and uh if
you do that sometimes you you will be
able to
find some some more advanced
combinations
but um yeah
there shouldn't be any pressure for you
to like play exactly like the
the engine like recommendation every
move like oh sure
usually you should err on the side of
caution and and just keep
keep the game controlled and keep your
keep your options open
right that that makes perfect sense okay
so can we briefly go back to the
beginning on this one
actually let me uh i'm gonna make a new
chapter
and we'll just call it king's indian
and this will just be more of a test to
see if you you've internalized like the
move order
and hopefully it sinks properly first
with the knight
yep then pawn
okay so far i stick with my plan and
bishop
agree
so now i play d6 very good yeah just
discouraging e5
yep um let's imagine
let's imagine i play e5 just this is
kind of a test for you
how would you react so uh i think i take
great
i'll say takes okay and then here
um so is this the situation where we
said
i would just then oh no there's no pawn
to win back in this case so i don't know
that that makes sense
do i just move back to d7 here so
i want to pause for a moment and i want
you to like try and
visual or just see the big picture of
what's going on and
what just changed in the position after
the pawn took
there's something you you're clearly
seeing the night's attacked but yeah the
queens are searing each other
yeah very often if you can take your
opponent's queen before they take your
own queen
it's it's what you should do oh okay
that's
actually i mean that's good because
sometimes in these optional queen trade
situations
i'm unsure really how to evaluate it
yeah and the reason for it here
is when you take on d1 white has to make
some concession white either has to
undevelop the knights
or take with the king and lose casting
rights right and i still have counseling
rights
right and then next move then you can
safely move the knight
okay there's actually a bonus tactic
here if the king takes
um you can you can play knight g4 and
hit hit both pawns
all right and then you're winning a pawn
maybe if your opponent's really bad
they'll get forked
i hope my opponent's that bad that's
yeah that's my strategy in fact
just just hope really hard yeah uh okay
okay yep that makes sense so if the
queen if the d
file becomes uh comes open i'm black i
take the queen
yeah and this is common like across any
opening like when
when there's a trade like this you
should immediately see the option
and uh and usually go for it okay but
but we're in agreement that eventually
i'm i'm moving the knight
to d7 uh well unless except in that
situation yeah right exactly
um but okay more often white will play a
move like knight knight f3
okay uh now i castle and let's say there
should be two
okay um
so now knight to c6
um it was a right right idea that you
want to
continue development um and it's not a
bad move but
usually you should play e5 first okay e5
yeah to really just pressure the center
got it
and um if they are to take
let's review this okay so this one is
where i take
i'll take your queen
excellent yeah and then this is what we
reviewed earlier and um
i think here it's not necessarily about
just purely memorizing this it's just
about understanding the flow of the
variation
and that you're winning the pawn back
when the knight lands on e5
right um so let's say a castle
um okay so i think now i develop the
knight and put pressure on d4
right and here
um yeah you're putting a lot of pressure
because you have two attackers but your
bishop is also
kind of applying extra pressure so more
often than not white will play a move
like d5
um okay so i think here we said i go
back to e7
and let's say i play a move play a move
like rookie one
okay so this is usually where i start to
be ambivalent about like are we now in
the middle game would we say
so now yeah you've castled you you've
developed most of your pieces
and once you get the structure yeah
especially with these
like the center pawns for each collar
this is where you should really look to
uh to expand on the king side on the
king side okay so
um i mean i guess i might start thinking
about so i'd still be looking at my
bishop and maybe d7 for the bishop or
maybe thinking about h6 g5
um remember what we talked about earlier
because you there's one like pawn
there's one clear pawn move you want to
achieve
um okay so this is where i i might move
this knight back
in order to open up here yeah okay and
yeah knight g7 is fine
um you oh or h5 or h5
or e8 very often like let's say you play
a move like 98 which is also completely
fine
yeah you'll end up playing f5 and then
returning the knight back to f6
right and then you want to get an f4 and
you want to
continue building up your attack and
your p your pieces can can
get into the game um very very nicely
right um i don't know if you'll ever if
you'll get the chance
to uh get a lesson from akaru
but hikaru's been known to play the
king's indian
at the highest levels and he routinely
will get positions like this
where he'll just destroy his opponent on
the king side um so it's an opening that
that's used at the highest levels and
like even at your level it's still like
intuitive to play
right um and then perhaps going forward
i can recommend if if you like if you
type into youtube
nakamura king's indian yeah you'll find
analysis of like his best kings indian
games and
you'll get a sense of like how how the
middle game attack can unfold
and so to go really back to high level
again just so
i'm understanding this is all if my
opponent plays d4
if my opponent opponent starts with e4
then i'm going with the other routine
so potentially this is like potentially
uh where i'm
starting with uh what what did we decide
on that i'm starting with
uh c5 and d6 was it
sicilian dragon yeah dragon yeah so
i didn't quite explain like usually when
i teach this to
to new students i explain why they call
it the dragon
um maybe we can review it just
uh just real briefly and do you remember
what to do here is black
so i think it was here good
i take great
um and then now do i start sort of a
king's indian setup on the list now you
do
yeah so you'll kind of see the overlap
of ideas
and the reason they call this a dragon i
i think is for two reasons uh
the main reason is that um this bishop
on g7 can later
breathe fire across the board it's a
very powerful
piece um this is also considered the
head of the dragon
so it's it's like a very powerful kind
of defensive setup very difficult for
white to actually crack
yeah it's sort of uh i mean i see it in
the same way that i see a bear when i
look at five stars in the sky it's sort
of a big
vague dragon but i think i think i
understand what you're saying yeah you
have to maybe hallucinate
uh a lot to see it but um
yeah if you can achieve the setup i'm
not sure about that alexa wanted to
chime in there
oh wow um but yeah if you can achieve
this you're not going to lose
in the opening in your alexa i've sent a
link to your phone with instructions
alexa stop it that will happen every so
often apologies for that
that's okay uh okay so then at this
point
then i'm trying to remember am i now
looking to bring my knight out to c6
right knight c6 and um
and really i gave you a starting point
yeah
um as you as you maybe play
this these openings in more games then
um
based on on what you're running into
that's where you you want to
um kind of expand your knowledge um
but yeah knight c6 very often the bishop
can come to d7
keep in mind this plan your book wants
to come to c8
and you always want to be looking for
opportunities in the center
with your knight pressuring this pawn
your bishop pressuring the diagonal
so um yeah so hopefully this will be a
good starting point and can offer you
some
some interesting games and this will
hopefully not
really put me at a disadvantage if
someone were to
uh observe that i'm learning this
i don't think so yeah i mean there are
like weird tricky gambits
but i think like as
especially in preparation for a
tournament like pogchamps
you you want to you just want to build
up
kind of your um your your knowledge of
the openings that you're playing
right and then um and focus more on on
kind of
uh middle game strategy tactics and then
as a tournament uh gets closer then it
probably makes sense to prepare more
specifically for each opponent
maybe to do so a bit more secretively um
and i am aware that like you do have a
few different weapons in your repertoire
apart from what we looked at today
um from from when we we met a while ago
so you might bring back
some some uh some other weapons
um depending who you're playing and
depending
what is known about uh what they're
being taught on on stream right
right and i should be deploying
opposition research on them
exactly yeah yeah um and that's
something where like i'm happy to help
or whatever coaches you're working with
should should also be doing um there
there's a website where
if you know anyone's leeches username or
chess.com username
you can plug in their username and see
basically their whole game history
what openings are most likely to play
what they score with
each opening it's a very powerful tool
it's called openingtree.com
and you can uh i mean you can use it
yourself but that's what i use to
to really do opposition research and
this is all it's not like when the
patriots were filming people allegedly
and stuff like that this is all totally
kosher
so it's all it's all public yeah um
right there's nothing
there's nothing against like preparing
deeply for someone before a game
using whatever databases engine analysis
um but during a game you're going to be
all on your own
and that's where you really have to to
just be in your your
top mental form and and use kind of all
the
the insights and and the strategies
you've been working on
beautiful beautiful well it's a lot to
bear in mind but i think
i think my goal is to have probably
three different ways i could go as white
to be less predictable
and then some options as black which it
sounds like it's what we're developing
where i can deal with the most common
openings
that i would that i would uh deal with
and then i probably need
some general strategy if white plays
something
wacky sure and that's actually like if
if white does like weird stuff like g3
or knight f3 um or c4 like there's a lot
of like first
moves that we it's hard to get to all of
them
um and that's why king's indian is like
a a nice opening choice because this
is your general strategy right
so even if you just remember like these
simple arrows for black that will enable
you to
meet most openings with like just a
solid approach that will just get you
into a middle game
where hopefully you can outplay your
opponents because you're better than
them
yeah absolutely absolutely